good morning believe nation today's
message is overcome your fears over to
you Gabrielle Bernstein how what's the
first step to overcoming the fear or
transforming the fear to witness it to
be to be the non-judgmental witness of
it to look at it and say something's got
to give right so so if you're unwilling
to look at your fear head-on and honor
it and and witness I always say if you
don't show up for what's up it will keep
showing up so looking and saying you
know I witness my resistance and you see
that fear as resistance it's right it's
fear as the resistance to what it is
that you desire and in the absence of
resistance you become a magnet for what
you desire
now when you let go of that fear and you
transcend that fear that's when you
start to become a super attractor that's
when you start to let what is truly of
essence for you into your life what is
truly of service for you into your life
what is true happiness into your life
and so looking at the fear witnessing it
calling it by its name and even if you
don't have the tools yet what happens is
is when you look at the fear and you're
like oh I see this fear I see this
resistance I see how it's blocking my
life and I choose to see it differently
that's when you're listening to an audio
like this that's when a book like yours
will fall off the shelf a catalyst yeah
you know exactly you open up your
consciousness pretty much you crack open
your consciousness to find solutions
rather than find problems right and so
when you're not looking at the fear
you're just living in the fear and
you're believing in the problem but when
you witness the fear and you're willing
to see it differently you start living
in the solution I think the key to
overcoming your fear is the awareness of
the fear I think most people aren't even
aware of their biggest fears that are
holding them back on a daily basis in
their business and in their lives what
often happens is somebody gives you an
opportunity right come speak at this
event there here's this project that
work with this person or go on this date
whatever it is you get an opportunity
and the real fear you have is that
you're not good enough
that you're gonna fail that you're not
gonna give a good result that's really
the fear deep down inside but you come
up with I don't have the time to do it I
don't know the time to do it is the
biggest BS excuse of all time you may
not be making the priority to go out and
do it but we all have the same amount of
time you should never say I don't have
the time you can say I choose not to do
it I choose not to make the time but as
soon as you say I don't have the time
you abdicate responsibility you are in
control you get to pick what you do with
your 24 hours every day it said one
thing that is equal across every human
being we all have 24 hours so we
disguise our real fear with some
practical reason right we say we don't
have the time we don't have the
resources blah blah blah whatever it is
but really it's some kind of fear and I
think I think that it's the case for a
lot of people so many of our fears are
so subconscious and we're so we do it so
automatically every single day and we've
convinced ourselves that there's a
logical reason behind it so the first
step in my mind is the awareness of the
fear the awareness said it's not a lack
of resources the awareness has not a
lack of time and it's really that I'm
just afraid that I'm gonna fail and I
don't want to do it anymore
so awareness of the fear is the first
thing next thing is do you have a wire
to get out of it is it important to
break that thing is it important to
crush through that fear do you have a
strong enough reason to make a painful
change and when you do the third step is
to start to catch it and you often can't
catch it in the moment usually comes
afterwards usually you're meeting with
somebody and you do the same thing that
you always do and you don't catch it in
the moment you catch it the next day
it's a guy I did it again I didn't I
should have said that I should have done
that and I didn't I did it again I
succumb to my fear again and when you
have that awareness what you'll find is
the awareness that's getting closer and
closer and closer and closer to the
moment where it's actually happening so
you started off and it's like the next
day when you realize it and then next
time with me a couple hours later the
next times a couple minutes later and
then you get to that magical moment that
magical moment where you caught yourself
just before you take the action you're
meeting with somebody and they're giving
you a project and you're about to back
away the words are about to come out of
your mouth it's about to happen again
the same pattern that you've always done
forever and ever is about to come out
again and you have that magical moment
to catch yourself and choose to be bold
to overcome the fear to push through it
and take a separate action so they go in
the same path you always go swerve and
go this way and when you do that it
gives you the muscle to do it again and
every time you get to that point it's an
become easier and easier and easier and
easier easier so one for me is
understand what your real fear is I
think we have the awareness to have a
strong enough why they get out of it and
then three get closer and closer and
closer to the moment where it's
happening and then choose to be bold
choose to be powerful and choose to push
through your fear so the question today
is I'm curious what is one of your
biggest fears as it relates to life or
business not like a fear of snakes but a
biggest fear that you have that you feel
is holding you back in your business
somehow leave it down in the comments
I'm curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Paul Rogers
Paul thank you so much you're picking up
a copy of my book your one-word really
really means a lot to me man and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
best
[Music]
where every milestone while you might be
excited about the milestone there's a
part of the milestone that you don't
want to face are you hearing me and
listen to me I knocked out the
coursework boom got it done in order ET
why did it take you two years ET after
you finished your coursework why did it
take you two years to get started with
the dissertation I'm gonna be 100 with
you
there was one look knocked all the
coursework out but when I finally got to
the dissertation I had to get to that
demon I had to deal with it I had to
face it face what we're not talking
about elementary school middle school
high school I've had a professor or to
tell me in college that you will never
get your dissertation that that that
while you're writing has improved but in
terms of your analysis like you are not
critical enough to do a dissertation are
you hear what I'm telling you we're
talking about look math I love math
coming up why it is what it is so please
excuse my dear Aunt Sally like it is
what it is right it's not subjective
writing is subjective I've had teachers
to look at my work at it and and rip it
in the park and the fear to fear what
the fear of rejection rightness is if my
teachers were so subjective
I put my whole heart into it I put
everything I could put and they tell me
edit it again a revision after revision
and it after are you hear what I'm
telling you I had to deal with the fact
that writing has never really been my
strong suit and even though I've worked
hard and I put in hours and hours in the
back of my mind I in the back of my mind
I could hear the teacher say Ichi you
don't have what it takes to get a
dissertation I'm a grown man dealing
with that fear I'm a grown man I'm
dealing with the rejection of getting
all that read all that read on my paper
of having to do it over and over and
over and over and come on come on
somebody fills me you feel like you'll
do a hundred and twenty percent you'll
give everything you have and it still
won't be enough I feel you I was there a
part of the milestone is what if I give
everything
what if I put my whole art my whole mind
my whole soul into it ET and it's not
enough what about doing and I fail and
so I feel you so you're just like you're
not gonna do it at all because you
rather not do it and find out the truth
and I'm telling you got to babe you
gotta face your fear and you guys do it
anyway had to face his fear that's right
yup I know you see ETV smoke and you
right I am B smoke but it don't mean be
smart without fear and don't mean be
smart without little anxiety
it don't mean be smoke and I'm just 120
percent sure no I have to live by faith
- and I made up in my mind ET you've got
to go after eat look I finished my
coursework it took me two years why cuz
it took me two years to get over the
fear it took me two years to get over
the anxiety it took me two years to
finally say good I'm here I come Goliath
you might be taller than me you might be
bigger than me you might be stronger
than me but I'm coming and I'd rather
die trying
I'd rather die going after this
dissertation I'd rather give everything
our guy really give a year I'd rather
put in work and fail to not try it off
there's a scene in there where you
talked about bullies and running from
danger and things like that when you
were trying to help this kid yeah what
happens is this boy is being harassed by
the neighborhood bully and his father is
encouraging his son to beat up this
little boy mm-hm this scene you know I
wrote this particular scene in the
script and I was trying to think what
can I write to encourage this boy to
handle this situation you know with this
bully in the neighborhood and I'm and
I'm spending days trying to hear what
can I say - boy and finally I came up
the answer and it was a situation that I
as a child had encountered about his age
I went to a school in Arizona that was
mostly Indians from the reservation and
there's this one Indian kid who just
didn't like me and every day he chased
me home from school and and I'd had to
run my dis gas station and this mechanic
had watched me being chased by this
Indian kid every day and finally he just
couldn't handle it anymore and he
stopped me and made me face this boy and
I told myself you know I'm
I was I told I'm scared and and he says
well and the money said to me which is
pills still true which I remember is
that he says you know that running from
your fear is more painful than facing it
and that's something I've always
remembered and in this what I relate to
this boy and of course eventually he has
to face this fear in the film